hey everybody it's Mike freder here with
on call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control scl2 d3.1 3.2 employee
architectural designs software
development techniques and system
engineering principles that promote
effective information security within
organizational
[Music]
systems so hey if you're at def
contractor who feeling overwhelmed tired
and alone trying to understand all this
cmmc DS and nists sp00 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your companies on
call compliance Hero Let's jump into it
so I will tell you I like to divide how
this control is answered into two groups
group one excuse me is is two is is the
small to midsize businesses who do not
develop their own software have small
simple systems and who ultimately there
really isn't much to answer here on this
control because they're using
off-the-shelf software and security is
handled by Third parties and in that
case the answers are pretty simple for
the rest of the companies who are a
little bit larger have more complex
networks and especially those who
develop their own software especially
that software used to store transmit or
process cui this will be one of the
longest control answers for you the
reason is because you are going to have
to detail a lot of different points in
your plan about how each aspect which
touches cui is secured and how it
evolves in continuing meeting security
to understand more of this I think it's
best to go straight to the assessment
points here now to help with giving you
a more complex answer we are using an
example from a larger Network that does
in fact develop its own software it has
a more complex setup if you have a
simpler company well your answer will of
course be a little more simple so let's
dive in uh three assessment points one
determine if architectural designs that
promote effective information security
are identified uh if we were to answer
this again I'm not going to give the
most complicated answer here but uh we
might say that it's identified within
system security plan in addition VLS are
in place to promote uh an effective
Network architecture or maximum security
and efficiency within the network and of
course whenever our code is developed uh
we are using best-in class and best
practices when it comes to architectural
designs for software creation next
assessment Point determine if software
development techniques that promote
effective information security are
identified uh so we may say hey this is
implemented via code compilers debuggers
malicious code scans and testing used
during any relevant application
development uh again assessment Point
number three determine if systems
engineering principles that promote
effective information security are
identified we might say implemented
identified within the system security
plan and again we may identify all
throughout this plan because that's
really what this is all about is
architecting a system that is secure so
uh more assessment points determine if
identified architectural designs that
promote effective information security
are employed so are we actually using
some of those more secure designs in
what we're building uh again another
sample answer would be implemented
throughout the information system
examples are vlans and system
segmentation separation for air gapping
and just an example answer there next
assessment point is determine if
identified software development
techniques that promote effective
information security are employed uh
implemented via code compilers debuggers
malicious code scans and testing used
during any relevant application
development uh pretty simple and
straightforward there and then determine
if identified systems engineering
principles that promote effective
information security are employed again
we would say hey this is you know
effective information security is
employed through the system uh can be
demonstrated in a variety of ways and
there are examples throughout this
system security plan pretty good way to
do it again the assessors may have their
own set of things that they want to
actually sort of investigate in person
uh but again as far as the system
security plan I think those are more
than adequate answers and we've
certainly got them to pass so hey at on
call we work with defense contractors
just like you who have had this DARS
nist itar and cmmc compliance stuff
dropped in their laps like a seagull on
a sunny day we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps gray
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to then more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now out if
you love the content we're putting out
here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash the Subscribe button to get
the latest compliance content as soon as
our compliance n roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next
[Music]
one